hey ice gum resumes Pierre pack today
we're gonna play with you a program it's
out on Steam so I guess it's a game it's
called face ring here we are
this software is still in development
I tell you know something is gonna be
great oh here we go
is he - is he talking to me whoa I am
that dang how this is some weird shape
how's it going right it's cool pretty
pie why am I wearing these ugly-ass
glasses
why is my lip sync like I'm speaking
Japanese ha ha stop laughing you're
making me laugh okay again Oh sir oh
stop it I'm so cute
I'm so cute I'm so gay I'm looking at
your dick oh the life is too kid I can't
are there more like what is this this
[ __ ] steam [ __ ] just shut up stop
adding me as a friend it's not gonna
happen
you wanna see my boobs oh my god is
Eliza from frozen
this is the weirdest [ __ ] ever hahaha ah
oh you're so funny this is the cutest
thing I have ever seen in my tire left
oh my God my face is vibrating my face
is a vibrator this is a weird furry
fantasies going on here
Lord Buddha chord oh ma I will take a
shot oh my god the ice I ate Josh you
thought you were gonna sleep tonight huh
well think again
Midori Chung what the [ __ ] hello that is
so sick i that is the most ago thing
I've seen in my entire life and I've
seen some sick oh my god Alois ching
chong ching chong ching chong meow ching
ching chong now I'll exterminate all
Janeiro's I will [ __ ] only be a loss I
will [ __ ] you tonight
I will [ __ ] your tonight do you know how
much [ __ ] I mean like I can get it
though y'all know y'all know I'm - oh
god this is freaky I didn't know you
look so hot oh I just wanna [ __ ] you up
like a little [ __ ] I'm sorry I didn't
realize what I'm saying here we were
cake Zeb arrows and then we will eat
them tonight wait we work with the mouse
oh shut up Ferg I keep forgetting that
detail son of a [ __ ] that's more like
it
I need to work on my evil laugh ha I
will slap that booty ho all night long
all night long girl my anaconda don't my
anaconda don't
I am in the bathroom season I make
meatballs and I put them in my butt and
see how many I can fit so far my head
score is 5 please can you try and cook
me some meatballs that would be great ha
ha ha you here you can take me me I'm
having way what Shawna did I am a dragon
oh my god much um I I don't remember the
meme oh it's my own meme I forgot my own
meme someone help
I am moving my eyebrows like that
looking at can you see them eyebrows
move okay yeah I would [ __ ] eat you
and then I will lick you and then I will
[ __ ] you out and then I would eat you
again and then I will [ __ ] you out and
did a light last night fluffy fluffy
chan bent over to get some ice cream and
ice I saw that booty and I was like that
is some sweet ice bowling
yuck yuck I'm stuck I like as a cat sake
on I was like ah I stopped it outside it
Becky Becky you crack me out Becky stop
making jokes and then it's at that stop
with the jokes of a guy you got to make
me wet myself
not again Becky come on you think you
eat burger burger a queue you got it all
wrong oh my god
I could do this all day this is amazing
the future is here I'll like if you
enjoyed this episode
I very much appreciate it and I'm gonna
keep playing with this kitty meow meow
meow now now now brofist